it's important I think to know that's
theory because I think there's a
mythology in the United States that
America kind of got rich as a result of
entrepreneurial activity and free
markets and lack of regulation and for
sure those were important elements but
what we need to understand is that for
most of our history from about 1800
until about 1950 we acted economically
pretty much the way China does today in
fact it's interesting to go back and
read the discussions among the founding
fathers Adam Smith wrote The Wealth of
Nations published it in the same year
1776 as of course the Declaration of
Independence Smith argued for example
that America had its greatest advantage
in raw materials timber and iron ore and
cotton and things like that and Smith
actually argued that America should not
industrialize England was the industrial
power and America should feed England
with raw materials there was Alexander
Hamilton who said no no no that's you
know Smith has it wrong we can't become
a great industrial power and we should
and there was a big debate with
Washington and Hamilton kind of on one
side of the debate and Jefferson and
Franklin on the other side but the war
of 1812 was a war we almost lost because
we didn't make shoes or rifles or
anything that we needed to fight a war
and that convinced Jefferson that he'd
been wrong and so from that point
forward the US government engaged in
active promotion of the development of
key industries of infrastructure of
Technology the advances of science and
so forth
so we had the Erie Canal the telegraph
was invented and developed on the basis
of government funding and partnership
with private industry we had of course
the the National Railroad
Transcontinental Railroad that we had in
in the early 1900s original Wilson saw
to the development of an American
shipping industry and created the
National Advisory Committee on
aeronautics to promote US aircraft and
aviation industry so it's important to
understand that there was a long
partnership between industry and
government in the United States that
promoted this development of wealth
producing capacity the Homestead Act is
a brilliant example America's biggest
industry in the 19th century was
agriculture and the Homestead Act
provided agricultural land so
essentially factories to the populous
and variable cost from the government
and and and the proceeds of that reused
to fund the land-grant universities the
big state universities that dominate our
scene today and to promote agricultural
technology so that was the basis of of
our wealth producing capacity
in the early 1950s in the United States
had a level of consumption that was
about 56 57 percent of GDP very similar
to the head of many other countries the
great fear of our leaders after World
War two was that without the war
production the economy would slip back
into the great depression that they had
all experienced in the 1930s and they
had 15 million men and women being
demobilized from the armed forces all
coming back looking for jobs and the
question was Wow where are the jobs
going to come from and with Europe in
ashes and Japan in ashes it was obvious
that an export-led drive was not likely
to be successful and so the focus was on
promoting domestic consumption as a way
of replacing the wartime production and
providing jobs for the returning
demobilized service people and so every
effort was bent in the GI Bill and GIS
were given preferential assistance in
getting mortgages for houses people were
able to deduct the interest on time
payments for consumer durables so all
kinds of measures were taken to make it
easy to consume by the mid-1960s
consumption as a percent of GDP was up
to 62 or 63 percent by the mid 1970s
there was up to about 67 percent by the
mid-1980s it was approaching 70 Perce
today it's about 72 percent it's has
been this huge continual increase in
consumption and reduction than in
savings in the US and an investment and
ultimately of course this has resulted
in big imbalances